hey it's Jay Mohr from Boston to or tame
or some monsters we saw unless I'm
seeing Fred hood as good a comic in many
ways there is I've ever back in the day
you talk about straight j4j more in a
lot of ways is is so talent you so tis
acting his [ __ ] standard wire he was
great Jerry Maguire nice he's he's a
beast he's not overdoing him on the road
Jamerson started I used to prefer Jay
Mohr and Artie Lange those are the two
Jesus yeah because of how I hung dozes
this was in 2011
well funniest guardian J Moore who I
bought through whom I know very well why
are you mom's away I started opening for
Artie was I was at Caroline's Caroline's
in 2011 Lewis fir and ax used to just
book me to like open for everyone so I
was opening for Richard Lewis and
Richard Lewis he's notorious for this he
will not sit in the green room in
between shows he just will not sit
anywhere she go outside and goes back to
his hotel that's what he does he doesn't
mind and he just shows up for first date
game time that's what he does when I
just want to talk to her smiles won't do
anything he has sold out 400 T is it
every night sold out I literally have
ten minutes of material at most 12
minutes stretching the [ __ ] out of my
sin i'ma do comedy for 18 months but
they're havin the MC weekend shows the
Louis's like see something whatever so
I've been doing it's fine
Thursday night show is fine it was the
same thing they give me the light at
nine minutes that means Richards there
bring up Richard do your last joke
Richard Lewis fine fine fine Friday
night Saturday night shows great
Saturday 8 o'clock fine everything good
now it's my fifth show Saturday ten
o'clock goes and I [ __ ] like
clockwork nine minutes I know I'm gonna
do my [ __ ] you know whatever newbie
bit closer blah blah blah who cares
bring up Richard Lewis 9 minutes I get
there
no lie ooh so I'm like what's going on
and then a couple of minutes go by I'm
stretching it out whatever I see Lewis
in the back going like this with his
hand being like keep going keep going
why dude I had 10 minutes 12 if I
[ __ ] stretched it 58 minutes let me
tell you Richard I Richard Lewis in the
car service back to his
tell had gotten into a car accident had
hittin a drunk driver he was fine had
hit rich Lewis the police wouldn't let
him leave until everything was assessed
so he had nowhere to he couldn't leave
58 minutes dude I ask every single
person in the crowd where they were from
the only thing that I know I know every
state capital I was having people yell
at a state I would yell the capital I
was just so there's only 50 states ran
out of that then I had a gun then I had
a guy come up and tried two minutes to
stand the p-funk it blew me out of the
water
so I got him off then I had I was asking
people what they had for lunch I mean
literally I was like you don't
understand that's in the I had 12
minutes I did 58 [ __ ] minutes is it
worth like being at school and listening
I swear to God I bring up Richard Lewis
I'm like Oh finally I see light I'm like
thank God I see him he doesn't say
anything those guys give it up for David
my open the whole time I shoot [ __ ]
literally I mean people get paid edger
no not a [ __ ] cent not a cent I still
have to pay it 50 I still have to pay
for my [ __ ] cheeseburger have fun
Jesus Christ yeah any other Road stories
Jay Moriarity
well job well that's why I brought that
Richard Lewis thing up yes already Lange
saw that Artie Lange's one of the guys
in the back and I come on cuz Artie's a
Comics comic I come off and Artie's like
dude he goes I do exactly what was
happening he said I was telling Lois
I'll go up there I'll say her husband
Greg Lewis was like no he's got to learn
he's got a long and I'm but but 58
minutes right
like you live I was almost gonna [ __ ]
kill myself I swore I was gonna [ __ ]
start mill slitting my wrists with the
butter not just entertain you don't have
the material let's stand I can't do
anything so Artie Lange sees that and
then the way it worked out what's art
he's like listen man I'm gonna bring you
on the road and he drove me all the way
back home to my house he's the nicest
human being all guy great Artie Lange
was great he's the best person in the
world and this is already was you know
sober then and he was saying any sober
now by the way I'm happy to see Artie's
like sober and already uh
at that point he was sober and um he was
like listen man I just want a guy you
know like you young young guy seems
hungry nice guy good family he's like I
just want you to like you be with me in
between shows like we get out of the
green room we walk around we just stay
away from the booze stay away from the
girls like you don't have any habits and
I said I don't and he was like and he
was like yes you come with me and then
we would go on the road and this is
already you know 2011 it's just like
late 2011 he you know is Howard Stern
fans were [ __ ] vicious too like I
remember dudas meaning like felt like
they just want Artie and there's a
little work I performed that's what I
used to open I opened for him a couple
of times yeah they were all Howard Stern
fans the height of his powers yeah they
were so [ __ ] drunk rowdy it was out
of control
no literally Count Basie Theatre
whatever that holds 12 1500 [ __ ] sold
out I'm being serious literally
look this is maybe the second shell open
for Artie already was like hey you know
it's Count Basie it's Jersey like these
they're animals out there you know do
five minutes bring me up it'll be fine
I'm not lying you dude I had on I had on
this purple eye on this purple button
down shirt I don't know why I come out
there like please welcome stage Chris
Stefano you know half the people clap
whatever from the [ __ ] last row in
the upper deck as soon as I take the mic
out of the stand
perfect somebody goes nice shirt [ __ ]
explodes and laughter already has to
come they save you
Artie comes on the god Mike from the
back goes give the kid a chance give him
a chance he goes t-shirts socks I'll
give it to him they let me do like three
jokes they let me do like three jokes
and then a woman from the front was like
honey hunt like I could hear her she
didn't even nobody heard she was like
honey bring up Artie
angel I have so nice about brought up
our same thing I get on stage guy who's
big [ __ ] guy was drunk literally at
the funny people in st. Louis goes he
gets up and he goes
those are gay [ __ ] boots and that's
how it started yeah they [ __ ] yeah by
the way I don't condone the f-word I
just wanted to just want to say that's
what that guy said maybe that's a Modi
Philadelphia for Modi comes hot hope and
I think I was like he was like [ __ ] do
more how long do you toward art I toured
with already for the whole summer of
2011 2012 and then already told me he
was like hey man I think you know not
that I was a headliner yet he's like but
he's like you've opened for me like I
feel like I gave you the experience I go
try to work on featuring for other
people get in the Improv get on the
funny bones like Artie is one of those
comics that will never ever ever he's
like is so comfortable who he is he just
wants to see the younger comedians do
well he'll do anything he can to help
yes he's just like a great guy that's
why like when he was having his like
substance struggles like anybody would
try to help him cuz it was like yeah we
don't want to lose Artie yeah me know
like because he's just such a great guy
but now he's like totally how things on
stage just [ __ ] destroying again III
I've always said this they're two people
who I think are the funniest people I've
ever been around on on like a personal
when you're just hanging out of them
like geniuses genius-level Artie Lange
and Zach Galifianakis yeah those two
those two are to me in all my years of
doing comedy as far as like just like
it'd be like being around like raw
athletes those athletes where you just
go like Alden Smith and this guy's like
that's the best athlete or I've seen or
met you know whoever would be the freak
a slate is what I'm saying like
physically yeah but but like yeah but
you told me you say the best half they
never met right I mean he's 65 to 60 and
no Alden Smith yes okay whatever the
point is it's bad the point is it's a
night like like as far as just raw raw
genius and ability before me like and
improvise induce it where you just go Oh
Mike you're
so [ __ ] so that so then did you go
from RT to Jay Mohr Jay Mohr with a
shame working around it
Jay Mohr was kind of around that same
time I to 9/11 2011-2012 is when Jay and
Jay we would open I would open Jay was
great but every with Jay is like when
you're in the green with Jay it's like
he's always putting you in like
wrestling moves
he's [ __ ] teabag and you enjoy
wrestling last night yeah I've seen him
in like dry wrestle me too so I
literally would like literally sometimes
I would come limping out onto stage cuz
Jay like tweaked my back just puttin me
in some [ __ ] move and I was like in
pain so we so I was like hey man like he
would ask me first do certain date shows
like I just don't wanna get beat up
today so I'm just not I'm gonna pass and
then he you know wound up falling out
but I haven't seen Jay in years before
he saw him yes I feel he hasn't been
doing stand-up I think he's been doing
heroin I think he went to a divorce was
tough on stuff on and then you know that
wrestling coach at Palisades high yeah
he's the head wrestling coach Palisades
I Jerry was a high school wrestler yeah
it was great to see Jay again head
wrestling coach yeah that's amazing so
he's just not that into acting and stuff
like that anymore I don't know you'd
have to talk to me else come on the
podcast [ __ ] last night you got man
come on come on yeah I love that I just
said heroin and people like yikes
I was kidding but it seems like people
know more than I do clothes kid full
joke sorry Jay so sorry
so then you went so you went already
monster jay mohr monster and then what
amen and then already Monster J more
monster and then what happened after
that then I got on the shows guy code
and girl code which became popular shows
among college kids MTV Veejay that was
Schultz also on their shoulders on that
schultzy Charlamagne Lil Duval myself
Nicole Byers jessimae Peluso Jesus
Christ actually know a lot of Italians
and a lot of talent yeah yeah yeah and
then and then so we did that show and
that became really popular and then and
then I started you know I started
headlining on my own in about 2008 2014
on and I just started you know and then
that literally it's it's been crazy
because from 2000 I was telling Donny
this the other day from 2014 to 2019 out
of all those years of headlining five
years have had
lining I got one I made one bonus in
Boston but it was because it was around
Christmas mean selling out so you got
hit a certain percentage yeah until you
get the bonus to make yeah I made one
bonus and then in from 2019 to now it's
like 90% of them are bonuses so it's
been I feel like I you know headline and
like I've been grinding it for like ten
years which I know a lot of people have
been grinding it way longer but also a
lot of people way shorter so I just feel
like you know now it's like I have part
doing these podcasts and putting my
stuff on the internet I feel like I'm I
can give people and all I want to do is
give people a chance like hey see my
work if you like it judge around there
that's it just jut give me a fair chance
so I feel like I get that because of
these shows that I get to come on
well show people right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]